number one we've got a final solution of
fifty-five and very helpfully we also
have some lines of working there I
always love seeing working because it
means I can see what you're thinking and
so whether your answer at the end is
right or wrong I can know how you got
there and why what you guys reckon who's
in agreement 255 yeah got all of them
thank you very much and what's great is
if that wasn't right we could actually
backtrack through and say well maybe if
my working disagrees with sofi's where
does it disagree because that will
either tell me where she is wrong where
I'm wrong okay and so maybe if you
didn't get fifty five and you're working
dippers that maybe you can find that
point of difference okay thumbs up
there's this factorization here okay now
I know when I look at something like
this it's easy to look at just these
first two terms cuz factorizing usually
means take out a common thing right like
take an X out of that okay why isn't
that an answer why isn't it an answer to
say this for example
haven't I factorized it hmm has anyone
written down something like that in
Hagar's now it's not a lot of bad thing
to do it's certainly better than having
nothing however if I asked you for
example to factorize this factor is 63
okay you probably wouldn't be very happy
with me if I said well that's 60 plus 3
right 63 so that's um I know how to do
that that's five times 12 and then
there's also a plus three right what
you've done is you've changed the
question and then you factorize the
different thing
what do we use these for when we
factorize like why are they useful in
what cases have you seen that before
yeah yeah very good if you've got a
function if I said to you y equals that
and then I said hey can you graph this
can you show me what it looks like right
the x-intercepts I can read off from
here what would they be by the way minus
5 and positive great brother right right
track okay um 59 over 12 sorry who put
these sensor up what's your name
well okay do we have some an agreement
on 59 over 12
before I come to your question which I
will answer do I have any agreement on
fifty nine over twelve what do I have
different answers
who's got different answer to that what
did you get
it's the mixed numeral version of this
same number so what was your what was
your what did you write as a mixed in
what did you write four and eleven on
twelve was does that match what you've
got yep okay now I'm gonna ask you guys
a question
mix new roof what do we call these guys
again improper fractions are they
different numbers they're not are they
you could convert back and forth between
the two do you think one in this
situation might be better than the other
and if so why a whole bunch of you
converted to the mix newer why did you
do it like it's extra work why did you
do it because the market likes it
I'm trying to guess what is in the
Marga's head it's not a bad way to think
if you can did you have a suggestion or
thought it's simple do you think this is
simpler than this I think it kind of
depends so the ones simplify right I put
the word simplify here wow something's
really shaking that isn't it is that
drive you crazy miss meets it's outside
that's fine it's that big when they do
that okay simplify right if something is
simplified which do you think out of
these two is simpler what do you think
this is question two right when I asked
you to factorize which one do you think
is simpler kind of depends doesn't it
what was that thing you told me we could
do when we factorize you could read off
what intercept what was that
the X intercepts right but just suppose
you knew what the X intercepts were and
you wanted the y intercept that's also
something that's used to when you graph
right which one of these is easier to
read the y intercept off it's actually
the first one because the y intercept is
right there you have to do sweet nothing
to it you're like BAM there it is okay
so there is simpler it's kind of what we
call context-dependent
right it's a it depends on what you want
to do next cuz there's no next actually
an answer to your original question you
can but it doesn't matter either these
are the same because as you told me that
the same number or maybe we have one
thing just have
look at the original question the
original question three it gave you some
fractions did it give them to you as
improper fractions or as mix numerals it
gave them to his makes numerous it's
just like a teeny part of me that thinks
I'd like to give it back in the form
that it was given to me okay but they
both find you'd get a tick on both of
them okay